now i would like to welcome to
our
meeting
uh aishwarya
raira is a data scientist at episodes
llc with two years of experience around
building machine learning and
data-driven solutions that provide
inference on healthcare data
she is now delivering and maintaining
and
to end ml solutions
so i'm just going to pass it to you
aishwara thank you very much for uh
being here
um thank you for inviting me
i'm going to talking about the
interpretable ml models at scale
so i am ashwara everyone and
i am working as a
data scientist at episodes lmc
i am a first time speaker great uh feels
great to be here and
very lucky to meet all of you uh i love
to build a machine learning and
dealership solutions so i have been
in this field for last two to three
years now and now i am building and
maintaining end-to-end ml solutions
um you can reach me out on linkedin or
you can reach me out on twitter um
anywhere is fine
so um a little about my company so i am
right now working at a social lc
um
it is a health care company that
provides um
health care that
works on health care data and analytics
and provides solutions for this
consciousness and quality solution they
at episodes also have machine learning
and an lp cloud platform that serves a
wide variety of common problems
and we
we have curricular 15 to 16 mm models in
productions which are used for variety
of use cases
on some of those
and some making books as well
so yeah the data is huge and
yeah we are serving healthcare and the
solutions with machine learning
today's today my
uh
interpretable ml models at scale so
i'll be going over the agenda
uh if it is visible
yeah
so um
in this talk i will be taking you
through thought process involved in
systems design the application
and importance of designing an ml system
um
the first part like um i think there is
a big context here and
you need to understand how another model
works and
why do we build an ml model so my agenda
is like this i'll be defining
what interferable ml models are
how you can build a self-service
integrated system
how you can optimize these systems for
scale
and what are the perks that comes with
an interpretable system
[Music]
[Music]
in every machine learning system what we
usually do is we're given some set of
features and when you get together get
out of prediction it can be a
probability it can be a reflection basis
these numbers can go portfolio
learning is understanding
um
why we have predicted a
thing why we have classified when a cat
was a top problem why we have acid
classified this as a cat
or when we are talking in health care um
what we are trying to do is if for
example if we have an ml model that
predicts the likelihood of a patient
getting diabetes then i want to know
why the patient is getting diabetes what
um so that i can recommend later uh what
are the lifestyle lifestyle changes that
the patient can make in their life
now what interpretability here we'll be
doing is it will be telling us why the
patient has been suspected of diabetes
now this may be because of his high even
sea levels it may be because
the microalgae is high there can be
variety of reasons in our feature set
that was given and because of which the
patient might have diabetes
so in this particular scenario um we
can't go around just say that patient
[Music]
getting is but we also need to explain
that why
do the patient will have the
diabetes
so interpretability is basically
determining the cause and the effect
it is the degree in which a model can be
understood in human terms
uh
yeah so i hope you understood um what i
mean by interpretable ml like this is
this is a slightly different from
explainability so in explainability we
give our future importances i think but
in interpretability what we do is
we try to
make this as human understands humanly
as understandable as possible we try to
keep things simple so so that anyone who
is taking or who is looking at our
predictions can understand that why we
have made that particular prediction
um there is a code by albert einstein
like if you can't explain it simply then
you don't understand it well enough
um i think in machine learning then we
are talking about modern
interpretability the end goal is to make
our predictions explanation so simple
that anyone can understand it
from this code i would like to take it
another way like you have to explain it
so simply that anyone can understand and
simply following the
or even uh five-year-old can understand
principle so whenever we are
interpreting a model of finitely
enterprising prediction the explanation
should be so simple that anyone can
understand that
so that was the major drive behind us in
building this solution um building
the entire system around this and next
i'll be explaining uh about how and why
did we build a self-service
interpretable system and what i mean by
a self-service integrated system
so
um
building a self-service into uh
integrated system i'll be talking about
the problem and the solution so before
going to before going into how did we
build a self-service integrity level
system i would like to bring some
context on why did we need to do it
see with the ml models built on domains
where we have
heavy compliance stakeholders deemed to
us for explanation for every prediction
in fact these type of systems help us to
learn from the models
um sometimes machine learning can even
help us in discovering patents in our
data that we even did we didn't even
know existed
but the thing with some ml models can be
that we can't just understand these
patterns from the predictions
but then
over uh
the importance of the features and
how they are being derived from the data
then we can we may make out
relationships other data and understand
um what are the patterns in the data and
maybe we can work only maybe we can
later work on a system that improves all
these things
um
taking my previous example
so
we have created
a model that predicts the likelihood of
a disease for a patient
now we want to automate this model we
want to automate and make suggestions
to the patient about some lifestyle
changes
now before going to the patient my boss
will be asking me um what are the
details how are you going to explain to
the patient that he is going to have
that particular disease so that the
healthcare provider someone else can
suggest those lifestyle changes in these
kind of situations we need to give them
the explanation
like
why i am saying that you are going to
have this particular disease or why my
model is saying that there is a very
high probability that you are going to
suffer from diabetes
so for some
reasons
the force being that the stakeholders
asking
for
for our explanation for every prediction
the client itself asking for the
explanation of itself and for building
the trust itself we decided to build a
self-service platform that stakeholders
and anyone deeming for explanation
for predictions can
you
understand
why they are predicting and what we are
predicting and uh when we give them the
explanation these are in a summarized
manner and an understandable fashion and
we are not just going to give them uh
the explanation in like the future
importance format but we give them
like the top five explanations you know
some and and then templates so that they
can understand and they don't have too
much information but
you do not have many we do not have to
less information either they understand
what is the cause and effect there
so these numbers tend to give them an
understanding of how the system is
working behind the scenes and overall
making them understand our ml models and
maybe again gain a credibility there
like there are models working fine and
correct on the correct data
in this talk i will be talking about
different learning speeds to building
the interpreted systems for different
use cases some of the use cases were
how we built 10 different models and
then integrated the integratable part
there
and how did they scale out the system to
meet the sla
so
first i will be talking about the
problem so the problem statement was
like this so we have to explain every
prediction
second uh we have to
predict and explain for one million
rules in an hour
we have to give summarize explanations
from n models to stakeholders and then
we have to take feedback from the
stakeholders like
if the prediction and the explanations
match if the model is taking correct
features into account for the prediction
itself
so um
uh in these four i can summarize what my
problem is taking first
now i will be talking about the solution
so
what the major design decision that we
took here was we
chose um gbts over neural nets so gbts
are gradient boosting trees and we
decided to
go with
some gbt based model over neural nets
and the major reason for that is its
interpretability um although many
techniques are available now to explain
neural nets and everything else as well
but still
with these uh with the other technique
overall speed of processing becomes a
major bottleneck for us so for these for
this use case um we were working on data
tabular data set and then after multiple
experiments that we did jubits did
outperform our neural networks so that
was the best point for us there
so
we went with gbts second we use sharply
values
for future importance so sharpie values
works on a game theory publishing game
theory and these tell us how to fairly
distribute
the payout among the features they tell
us how important each feature is and how
each feature is contributing to the
prediction itself
so these values help help to help us
understand
which features to take which pitch
features are important which features
are positively affecting the prediction
and which features are negatively
affecting the predictions so that we can
give out the
most important features in the summer
explanation part
uh
after the after
the overall sharpie values um
we used uh we generated the most
important ones like the top five and
then use those to generate a summary
after that
to manage the scale of the data um
we use salary task queues for
distributing distributed processing
so we divided the entire data in batches
and
then distributed across a different
instances and differed across different
codes so that we can
have we can utilize all of the computing
resources that we have and get the
the get the results in time
for data dashboard but for showing it to
the stakeholders we used streamless
so
when we stored our um
then we processed everything and
into the things
we developed the stream based dashboard
that the stakeholders can use to
understand okay this is the prediction
and this is the prediction explanation
so they don't have to go through files
and everything but we can just
click and drop and select over there
like okay this is going to be
if i'm going to given this member state
then this is the prediction and this is
why i'm predicting this so this makes it
very easy
uh easier for them to understand and to
access
um last
we gave them we provided some nice
explanation of predictions so we gave
them
the top five major game changes for the
prediction we fit those in the template
and provide
summarize instead of providing them tons
of features and the future importances
that they don't care about really i mean
they only want to see what are the top
factors that are important and what the
top factors which are making out the
prediction right
so um
yeah these were the major libraries that
we use we use scad boost we used
streamed for data dashboards um
we used sharp values the future
importances to understand to determine
which features were important and how
much they were contributing so that we
can explain those later
and we use salary based distributed
processing
so
this was our solution
we combined all these things and then
put it out on scale
so
next i will be talking about
the
optimizing part so
how did we optimize the entire thing
first game so first of all we
immediately switched to parking major
reason for using [ __ ]
was
because the entire thing is very
computationally expensive and park a
has a major impact which is on high
execution speeds faster io operations
and it consumes very less disk storage
and apart from this this is really
easily pluggable to other data
dashboards as well apart from it and
plug it to a cleaner as well and we can
get our
data in the dashboard
so
um here i will be talking about the
various steps we took to optimize
overall process along
apart from the key design decisions that
we take like after adding explanations
for everything
since it is a very time consuming very
compute intensive process the prediction
explanation part you can get predictions
from the given study very easily but
since sharp values calculation is based
on game theory uh it is very
computationally extensive so if you are
working with a very unoptimized code
base it it will become impossible to
meet the sls
so it is absolutely necessary to
optimize every bit of your code way so
that the only thing that is remaining
that is taking the time
is your shaft other than that everything
else is optimized we profiled the entire
code base we
took out chunks of functions and we
understood okay what is worm uh what is
taking the mode what what is taking the
most time and we optimized every bit and
piece of it so that the last remaining
thing was shaft
uh after after we did that
we
uh what we did was we converted our data
in batches so what we did we benchmarked
the data batch so we took out the system
we took we selected an instance and saw
what batch size
works best for this particular instance
and
then we the
we distributed our we broke our data in
those patches and then sent a centos
output distributed processing
one more thing that we did was we
branched out the predictions and the
prediction explanation
see uh prediction does not take that
much time but prediction explanation was
taking a lot of time for us so what we
did was um for faster
to provide fast predictions we branched
out we branched this out first we
provided the prediction to the
individual and later
in some more times some one half an hour
or more you can get the prediction
explanation as well so predictions are
immediately available uh and in some
more time you can get the traditional
explanation
lastly um
we auto scale the instances based on the
input size so since distributed
processing was involved senator workers
were involved we had a master slave
architecture
uh where
the
batches were distributed across
different cores and instances
and how many instances to launch and how
many and how to scale it was dependent
upon the input size that was given to us
so suppose if one million rows are there
and the batch size is 100 then we launch
our instance with respect to that
um
yeah so this is how we optimized for
scale and meta recently we processed
uh roughly one point one more than one
million rows in under an hour with
predictions and explanations
across 80 different ml models
so
lastly i will be talking about the forks
that come with interpretable mm
so
yeah
with interpretable emotions we get all
the predictions and explanations and
everything else
we can detect we can early detect the
data trip
if they
um how can we detect it we can see that
if the most important features are
changed for a given prediction yes
something is wrong there i mean
um
because of diabetes if the incident
value is not taken into consideration to
consider it then
there is some definitely something wrong
with this
so yeah we can detect
um how the features are changing and
which features are not important anymore
and
we can take that into account to
understand okay my model is scripting
now
these systems also give us
a sense check and give us an opportunity
to fix errors
um
with feedback loop incorporated the smes
or anyone verifying the predictions
inspiration
can help us
in predicting for the right reasons
um with multiple people involved here
with the be getting the feedback for the
emerald systems
we can
we can continuously improve our ml
systems and predict for the right
reasons
along with feedback
and these systems also help us in our
automl workflows so normally when we
incorporate automl workflow we tend to
train the model on certain data after
doing some daily six salary checks on
the data but with feedback system
incorporated um we get a better sense of
understanding where our model is lacking
on what type of data should we include
more
um
as mentioned earlier um since our system
was
very
since our system is our sensor domain is
very compliance heavy we we have to
follow compliance and we have to took
everything in our power to make sure
that we are predicting correct and we
are giving the right reasons uh the
prediction explanation part becomes very
important for us
these type of system also help us in
gaining the trust on our immune system
when we are predicting things for the
right reasons it removes the much
occurred fear or doubt or uncertainty
and analyzing us that stakeholders feel
because of commences some
that um
okay why are you predicting this
we can tell them that we are predicting
this because of
these particular reasons
yeah
so
these were the folks with interpretable
level
lastly
i will be talking about the key
takeaways that we got after
building such a system so we immediately
got to understand
what were the trade-offs between
explainability and performance
so like okay
in our case gbt's worked better for us
but sometimes what happened is your
neural network can
outperform gbt or any other more
interpretable system in that case it is
very much important to understand
um what is the thing that you want to
let go do you want performance or do you
want the explainability part because if
the limit is very important to you
then
choosing the right factors and choosing
the right designs is very important
second use parking parking is very
lightweight and the entire file
processing looks very smooth when you
are dealing with tableau data itself
third uh optimize as much as you can
so
like we did we optimized everything
in our functions we optimize every bit
piece of code
third uh sorry force it would be to keep
it simple
even if you're explaining something
don't over then the stakeholders just
give them very simple information and
lastly feedback
makes an ml model even better
so
yeah that was
my take on how we did interpretable ml's
models at stake
um
and i am open to questions now
okay thank you very much
um
let's check over here
in the q a
there's nothing in the q a and
let's check
here
do you handle feedback manually
here's a question from uh rishika
do you handle feedback manually or is
there an an automated system that
incorporates the feedback in improving
the automl workflow
so yeah for now um we are handling the
feedback manually but to automate the
process
it is already in the designs and we will
be doing that very soon
there's one question from ian
what was the biggest business when with
interpretability
was it to gain trust of stakeholders or
to find errors
i think both will be equally important
for us i mean stakeholders definitely
believed in us more and with compliance
and play i think it was
compulsory for us i won't say even
i won't say even if it was about trust
but it was a compulsory thing
like we have to have explanations for
our predictions
okay there is
uh
another question
what was the
from saya
sai sorry
what was the hardest thing for you while
building this system
so
the scaling part i think
because
when when you introduce the sharpie
values and all the computed sensor
processes in between the optimization
itself becomes very difficult because
you can optimize everything but that
particular part is always going to be
compute intensive so
distributing across different things and
then scaling in and out
was
what was a challenge for us but we did
overcome that
i think we can
um just wrap up and said that if anyone
else have any other questions please
reach out to
aishwara uh through the linkedin or the
gather town um
so i just want to thank you again for
your talk and also for being part of pi
data global
2021 thank you very much really
interesting
talk and thank you to all our attendees
as well for being
here
thank you for having me